so i've had a lot of comments on the
channel over the years being like joey
you should share your hair loss journey
as if i have some epic tale a dramatic
story arc infused with life lessons a
coming-of-age tale but in reality it's
not something i've really thought about
much hair loss was always in the cards
for me growing up my dad really didn't
have much hair and my two older brothers
shaved their head due to male pattern
baldness when i was around 12 years old
when they did that at the time i didn't
really think much of it probably for
like five minutes i said oh that's kind
of weird you look kind of dumb but then
the novelty wore off and they were just
my brothers the same brothers that i
always knew since birth but when it was
my turn and i started seeing symptoms i
wasn't so nonchalant about it growing up
i always looked older than i actually
was even right now that fact rings true
i'm 25 years old a lot of people think
i'm like 32. so when i was a kid i
really took pride in the fact that i
looked older than i am that way i could
boss other kids around and seem like an
adult before i actually was even though
i didn't have two brain cells to rub
together back then so when i was 16
years old my barber told me hey you're
starting to lose your hair i kind of
freaked out internally it's like this
spongebob meme where he's calm on the
surface but internally losing his
and i was like you know what this is
kind of a bummer now i'm gonna look
really old like i'm gonna look 40 when
i'm 17 but i didn't really do anything
about it i started to notice that my
hair was starting to recede at the
temples but it was slow enough that i
didn't feel the need to do anything
about it i was just hoping and praying
that my hair might last me somewhat into
university we should probably just fast
forward to photos of me when i'm 18
years old this is sort of high school
graduation territory you can start to
see that i'm receding at the temples
fairly significantly for an 18 year old
i definitely do not have like a squared
off head of hair at 18 years old and
this is the summer before i went into my
freshman year of university so into
university you can see that my hair it's
still there you know i it's still fairly
thick on top but definitely lots more
temple is showing if i had actually done
something about it i would have had a
decently full head of hair to work with
and potentially experience some regrowth
to the point where i would almost have a
full head of hair right now you and me
would be talking having this
conversation actually it's a one-way
conversation i'm just talking at you but
we would be doing this together and i
would have hair on the top of my head
but i didn't i was in denial i just said
you know what i don't want to worry
about it i don't really care that much
but i think i did care it did affect me
and we'll get into that a little bit
later you can already see by the end of
my first year there's a lot of temple
there and i don't know what i was doing
with my hair at the time but it was not
doing me any favors i was slicking that
right back kind of curling it back you
could tell this man is losing his hair
like a middle-aged man at 18 years old
and i think at the time it affected me
subconsciously uh whether i was aware of
it or not so i'd start to wear hats a
little bit more often trying to cover it
up but the hair loss got worse here's me
at the start of my second year there's a
lot more forehead i'm starting to keep
my hair shorter on top because
i noticed it would just draw a little
bit less attention to the fact that i
was balding i would keep my hair very
short on the sides as well just trying
to do some techniques that didn't look
absolutely ridiculous i didn't want to
look like i was trying to hide the fact
that i had a receding hairline i kind of
wanted it just to look clean and out of
the way but then it got worse and
obviously you know that's what happens
with male pattern baldness it doesn't
just
get better so here's me playing piano at
some
gig or something with my brother eli i
was cutting my own hair at that point
buzzing it all the way up to the sides
and then leaving it lengthy on top it
kind of is an optical illusion from the
side it makes me look like i'm kind of
going for that mohawk look
but it's not a great look i do look very
pointy my entire head kind of looks like
a crescent moon i think my third year is
when i should have bit the bullet and
shave my head i even started a youtube
channel in my third year and it was
called better ideas and i had hair and
you guys can tell it doesn't look that
great it was starting to do that weird
androgenic alopecia thing where it was
starting to get thicker on the sides
like right around the ears and then kind
of getting a little bit puby on top
sorry mom it just wasn't a very good
look it just didn't look fresh it wasn't
the best version of what i could be
doing and here's the weird thing
psychologically as to why i didn't shave
my head it wasn't because i wasn't aware
of the fact that i would probably look
better if i just bit the bullet and
shave my head but it was just the fact
that i had lived my whole life with hair
and it was almost like i didn't want to
say goodbye i attached a part of my
identity to my hair i almost felt like i
wasn't ready to become a new person by
shaving my head i wasn't ready to
present to the world that i'm a new
person now i finally let it go i'm no
longer in denial and obviously you don't
think these things consciously it's just
sort of a subconscious identity crisis
you have you're kind of at a crossroads
do i just let go of my hair as a
variable in my life or do i continue to
hold on to it for whatever it's worth
despite the fact that it's not serving
me anymore but i pressed on for at least
another year this is when it really
started to just not look so good i
definitely have this sort of like
bowl-shaped thing going on on my head
two semi-circles and from the top it was
starting to thin right on the crown so
here's the year before i shaved my head
everyone's looking suave here's all my
brothers here's a bald brother of mine
here's another bald brother of mine and
then some non-balds look at this
non-bald right here non-bald right here
non-balled right here then here's the
funny thing about daniel is actually
he's uh he was starting to recede here
but he actually did something about it
and now he has sort of you know more
hair like way more hair than he did when
he was losing it that's what happens
when you're proactive so good on daniel
for not denying reality so he can
improve upon it either way
my hair is really looking rough at this
point it's definitely like an advanced
jude law look and i don't have jude
law's face so it doesn't work as well
for me as it does for him so at the end
of my fourth year the summer between
fourth and fifth year i finally bit the
bullet and i shaved it off
all right let's film this video so i
shaved my head i think it looks a lot
better to be honest i was really
postponing that my hairline was like i
mean you can see where my hairline is
and i had like a little bit of hair kind
of like did i do this with and then you
turn my head it'd be all thin up here
looks like i'm not trying to hide
anything anyways and i sent some photos
to my friends and family being like yo
look i shaved my head and they're like
looks good dude
that's it you know i met with some
friends that summer and they'd be like
oh you shaved your head like yeah
they're like yeah it looks good man
that's it you know all that buildup for
you know 22 years or whatever it was led
to the reaction of people being like oh
looks good and then
treating me like they've always treated
me you know it's it doesn't really
it it's not a thing like it just doesn't
matter and what i've learned over this
whole process is that nobody cares even
when my hair was receding unless you had
somebody else who is really
self-conscious about their hair
they would probably compare it with you
and be like oh that guy's receding a
little bit more than me but all in all
you know nobody's thinking about your
hair more than you are and when you
shave it off it's not like a big reveal
and it's like the princess bride where
you have this giant glow up there's a
glow up in the princess bride no
princess diaries i think yeah it's not
like that nobody cares nobody cares
before you shave it off nobody cares
after you shave it off your hair is just
dead protein on the top of your head do
what's best for you in my opinion if
your hairline is receding to an advanced
degree
it probably will look better when you
shave it off but do i care if you shave
your hair off or not no so just make the
decision based on what's best for you
and funny enough since shaving my head i
feel like i have actually gotten more
confident especially when meeting
strangers and it's totally a
subconscious thing because i don't have
to think about the fact that i have an
incomplete hairline i don't have a
hairline anymore i literally can't have
a bad hair day i can also walk faster
because i'm more aerodynamic i can also
tell when it's raining quicker than
anyone else i can jump higher swim
faster i've basically become a god but
in all seriousness the moral of the
story i guess i can conclude from my
hair loss journey is that no one really
thinks about you nearly as much as you
think about yourself not even close most
people most of the time are not thinking
about you and that might be a little bit
of a hit to the ego but it's the truth
most people are mostly thinking about
themselves so to think that people are
like sitting down at a christmas dinner
thinking about joey's hairline is such a
joke but that's how our brain we always
think that's gonna happen the same could
be said not just about hair loss but
about a mole that you happen to have on
your upper lip or
a zit that you have on your forehead one
day it's a huge deal to you maybe but
really
you're just kind of like a background
character in most people's lives and
they're not really thinking about you at
all so why would you put yourself
through the trouble the mental distress
to um
to let that affect you so yeah that's
the story of my hair loss journey i hope
you guys got something out of this or at
least just had some fun getting to know
me better and you know kind of picking
apart a little bit of my history maybe
you could learn a thing or two from this
but if not
maybe you'll learn a thing or two using
today's video sponsor skillshare man i'm
getting good at this for those of you
who don't know skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes covering dozens of topics
everything from photography to
videography to learning to color grade
or tell stories better creative writing
cooking do you want to learn how to cook
you can learn how to cook on skillshare
do you want to learn how to code your
own website and make thousands of monies
you can learn that on skillshare too
whatever you're into there's probably a
class for it on skillshare and whatever
class you choose to take on skillshare
it will be extremely practical because
every class on skillshare is designed
for real life it's super easy to take
whatever you're learning on skillshare
and apply it directly to your real-life
pursuits that's why i always like to
mention the fact that i'm constantly
taking videography and editing classes
on skillshare because that's my
real-life pursuit i want to enhance the
things that i am interested in and
skillshare is just an awesome resource
to help you do that and skillshare is
doing this awesome thing where the first
1000 of you who click my link in the
description below will get a one month
trial of skillshare premium so make sure
to take advantage of that offer learn
something new explore your creativity
and as usual have a great time and if
you liked this video make sure that you
actually hit the like button because
when you hit the like button the
algorithm shoves my bald head into other
people's home pages helping them out
which also helps me out so it's kind of
a win-win for everybody involved this
whole better ideas community can grow
and that's good that's a good thing and
if you're lurking here and this is the
thousandth time that you've watched one
of my videos consider hitting that
subscribe button other than that thank
you so much for watching make sure to
check out the second channel because
there's lots of fun content on there and
i'm a lot more casual like i was in this
video on there so if you like this style
of video hit up the second channel it's
a great time other than that thank you
so much for watching and we'll catch you
in the next video
[Music]